[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the realm
table of dim lighting is YouTube fashion
and beauty guru Ingrid Nilsen
Ingrid's YouTube channel missglamorazzi
is full of fashion tips how-to videos
personal vlogs and it's become one of
the most popular beauty channels on
YouTube boasting 3.7 momomo million
subscribers and over 270 million video
views Ingrid has steadily climbed her
way to becoming one of the go-to
channels for fashion and beauty advice
and along the way her followers have
been getting to know Ingrid in her
up-close-and-personal vlogs most
recently Ingrid released a video called
something I want you to know coming out
where she makes the emotional
announcement that she's gay here's a
clip of that video alright I guess I am
just going to get right to it
there's something that I want you to
know and that something is I'm gay now
that video is 19 minutes long but it
turns out there's still plenty more to
cover in a near biscuit right and on a
typical episode of ear biscuits we go
into the background of a person we talk
about their growing up the process that
led to them becoming you know the star
that they are and there's a little bit
of that in this one but because this
announcement has is so fresh in her life
and it's been such a big thing in her
life that we just ended up talking
mostly about that and you know I gotta
say I'm glad that Ingrid chose ear
biscuits to come and unpack more than
details behind that vlog because this is
that she says one of the first times
she's talked about it since the video so
we talked about her childhood including
when she realized she liked girls the
environment she grew up in which was not
a place where she felt free to express
that to others and so she kept it secret
we also talked about the incredibly
intense process leading up to releasing
the vlog including breaking up with her
boyfriend
and the aftermath of the video including
fan reactions and whether or not she
thinks that being openly gay will impact
her brand we also address the Internet
speculation about her relationship with
Hannah Hart
the internet has officially shipped them
but have they shipped themselves stick
around for that okay enjoy this biscuit
with ingrid nilsen
k 96.4 don't encourage him too much i'll
go into the DJ voice if you want me to
coming up traffic on the tins weather on
the eights news is we got lizard in the
chopper he's gonna do is the give us a
traffic update i don't have yeah like um
like if you had a radio show ingrid what
would it oh you'd like to Lyla you know
delilah late night yeah yeah well it's
like people will call in and give
dedications like dedicate this song to
my wife linda who but she restates it
they don't play that oh yeah why i'm
yeah i'm thinking about the call that
was going there yes right so you like if
you were that guy you would call in a
Dalila tangra hey Ingrid my wife what a
bores her name where did I call her name
Darla sure I want to dedicate this to
Darla we're not currently together we're
separated and there's a restraining
order against me but I still love her
and I would like to dedicate endless
love to her
and then you would take that and you
would you would restore their marriage
right by dead in this song does uh wait
what's your wife's name again Darla
Darla and your name is Clinton alright
Darla this goes out to you from Clinton
good luck because he seems crazy and he
knows it and you obviously do too
because if they restrain here's endless
love right from a distance he's not
going to come within twenty five very
firefighters but here's the good news we
don't have to be good at radio right now
or two got a job he should have
dedicated from a distance that bette
midler song hmm
that if I had a really thought about
that joke that would have said that from
a distance that is a Bette Midler song
right
yeah from a yeah from a 100 from a
100-yard radius you were talking about
the fact that you just took a power nap
before this and I don't want people to
think that we've been living on the job
but we also took power naps right before
you showed it yes we have a mutual love
of naps
yeah we actually built nap like a nap
zone into our office yeah hey the couch
aka there's a loft with a couple of
recliners you didn't see it right no
exactly
it's unseen people don't know what's up
there we don't tell a lot of people oh
my god I need this because I sleep on
our couch at the office and I'm just out
in the open and Eileen is actually
creating a collection of ingred napping
photos in front of everybody
yeah I mean I mean who's going to and
fro at you're off I've been to girls
it's okay
me and two girls so it's not that many
people but I'm just out there in the
open
taking my power nap and Eileen will take
photos of me in various positions but
you need that they go on tumblr no she
keeps them for her personal collection
oh it's black
it's blackmail sighs lose your mouth
like sometimes she has pictures of me
with hats on my head she has pictures of
me with my mask you put the hat on your
head or she puts out here I put the hat
on my head so don't be different
sometimes I just need to pretend like a
beauty mask
well not quite maybe it's more like
shutting the world out right like this
is my world bow inside this hat her hats
in the face don't talk to her listen to
say it I mean like I was telling you a
second ago I set my timer for 30 minutes
because you know they say that the the
perfect power nap is 20 minutes and I
was like well it's gonna take me a lot
of fall asleep and can we back up
because I don't remove I just I remember
I was on the couch asleep yeah lay it
was on the couch we were having a
brainstorming session that ended with
Linc snoring okay there on the
whiteboard riding an amazing idea and
then I turn around and then he's just
his mouth is a gate no no you said I
have to go pee really yeah and so you
went to pee and awesome yeah
and I went to sleep it's a little time
it took you to pee we don't see about 45
seconds yeah so you know it says levy
and ideas were so and then when I got in
there I was like well I'm going up to
the NAB zone I'm setting the timer and I
did hear you going up the stairs and I
was like okay yeah but I woke up 22
minutes after it started right and I
probably took exactly a 20-minute nap I
didn't make it to the 30 minute mark I
felt incredible yeah okay now let's jump
into the deep end here you've got this
blockbuster announcement video that's
still reverberating through the internet
at the time of this recording four weeks
later you're coming out video ten
million views in the first month no it
has 10 million views
it does oh yes that's eight figures
that's eight figures ladies and
gentlemen I mean I haven't I haven't
gone back to that video in a while
because I put it up and it was just kind
of like this is it you know and I think
at least people I know that
have made coming out videos they kind of
post it and then they don't watch it
again because it's like this big thing
you put it out there and then it's kind
of like not your thing anymore it
becomes you know something that you put
out there for everybody so wow I just
had no idea was it a million views and
million and as you kind of described in
the video I mean this was a culmination
of 25 years of suppression secrecy
struggle why now the timing I mean the
timing just felt right I think that I'm
26 now and 25 was a really rough year
for me and I think it's something that's
just common in general with people
around that age when you're in your
mid-20s you're reevaluating everything
regardless of what your sexuality is and
so I was struggling with you know things
professionally personally with my
sexuality I always knew that I was gay
ever
I'm from my earliest earliest memories
and I was just I just felt so stifled
within my own self and I just felt like
I needed to break free and as much as I
tried to keep living this life that
first had been set up for me and then I
continued to just go along this path it
just it just felt like I was trapped and
I didn't like that feeling and as scary
as it was too I guess
accepted myself fully and then think
about okay well now that I have fully
accepted this what am I gonna do now
because this doesn't just affect me I
was in a relationship at the time this
affects other people it was really
really difficult so how long between
making the decision knowing that you
need to make a video and then posting
the video what was that time period I
mean when I decided Tim it really wasn't
that long
I kind of knew in the back of my mind
that I would probably want to post a
video but I remember being on an
airplane and just feeling like I was
ready because I had told people in my
life people in my personal life knew I
remember just being on this plane I
wasn't doing anything in particular I
was just looking out the window and I
just had this feeling of I'm ready I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this this week and
that's what I did because you had there
was a you describe the process in the
video at one point you talk about you
reach a point where you felt like you
needed to break free that's what you
just said it's either you know in in in
hearing people coming out stories it's
kind of there's a lot of either a point
where you break down or want to and then
make a decision to like you said break
free but that was something that it you
kind of had this process where you left
I guess left la yeah I mean you went to
New York yeah so last last summer I made
the decision to basically just drop
everything and get an air B&B in New
York for everything meaning your your
YouTube content I mean I was career I
bet well I didn't give up all my YouTube
videos but you know I had all of these
things lined up I had shoots lined up
and I basically just told everyone I
need this for like my personal sanity
because I just felt like I was being
worked into a wall a lot of it was self
induced because I I just I felt so
overwhelmed but I felt like I had to do
all of these things and they were also a
distraction from thinking about what I
really needed to be thinking about and
so I just told everybody I'm going to
New York so we're just gonna have to
figure it out and I told everyone that I
needed some time and that was that it
wasn't there weren't a lot of details it
was just I'm getting away you make it
work in my absence sir yeah
have to be on pause yeah and I literally
spent those couple months in New York by
myself in an air B&B and I explored the
city I wrote I read I listen to music I
just know in why New York I've always
felt a connection with New York my aunt
and uncle used to live in Connecticut
and I would visit them in the summers
and I remember going to the city for the
first time when I was about nine years
old and I remember just having this
immediate connection with it and it was
interesting because I was always such a
shy kid and very very introverted and to
have a connection with a city that is so
the opposite of all of that it was
something that I wanted to explore more
and I had never been to New York and
just been able to experience it it was I
was always there for work so I really
just wanted to have an experience in a
city that I felt a connection with but
it was kind of in solitude I mean you
didn't have friends there that you were
hanging out with I saw I knew a couple
people there so I would see them
periodically but I was in this place by
myself like I didn't have a roommate or
anything and most of my days were spent
on my own like a meditative state of
I've got to figure this out like walking
around yeah literally going to parks
like reading I mean you know we actually
went recently and I've always said
there's just something there's you can
walk in any direction for as long as you
want and you're constantly surrounded by
people and culture and it just there's
just something therapeutic about it for
me free I totally good but I can see how
it would be an isolated experience in
the midst of all that - so it's kind of
I think for the choice I think for me I
really needed that because I technically
wasn't alone because I was around a lot
of people but I was completely anonymous
being in New York City like I didn't
know a ton of people there I could just
walk outside walk aimlessly in whatever
direction see where I ended up and it's
really what I needed I think it was the
perfect environment how'd you come out
to anyone over the course of your life
I had she said you you always knew yeah
and there was this suppression and a
secrecy but my dad knew really really
really early on I didn't at that point
like I didn't know to say I'm gay but my
dad knew and he was just always
completely fine with it
meaning there was it was more of a
dialogue there wasn't a moment where you
came out to your dad because I was so
young - you didn't say you're gay you
just were like I like girls yeah pretty
much
and I remember I've never said this
before aside I've never told this to
people aside from my really close
friends but I had this really awful
nightmare as a kid that really stuck
with me for like a week or more
afterwards I had this nightmare in my
mind about being forced to marry a man
and I remember being so disturbed by it
as a kid how old I was like seven or
eight and I remember just waking up and
running to my dad and just crying and
crying and crying and crying because I
said I don't want to marry a man I don't
want to be with a man and he was great
he was so comforting to me in that
moment um I think he handled it
perfectly and he just said it's okay
you don't have to it's interesting I
think there's a there are people who
would try to explain away you being
lesbian as theirs there's got to be some
external cause and and they'll go to the
dad thing and it's a very powerful story
to say that you know the first person
you ran to with this with this nightmare
was your dad mm-hmm you know I think
that kind of shuts that down yeah right
off the bat
yeah and his reaction was what he just
said it's okay you don't have to that's
what he said to me and that moment is
just like stuck in my head because I
remember him saying that and feel
so relieved but then when I would think
about the dream that dream just stuck
with me and I I haven't had a dream
since that has stuck with me like that
one has I remember just being so
disturbed because I was also so young
and it stuck with me for over a week and
I just remember being like I had this
sick feeling in my gut when I would
think about it but even though the first
person you told your dad it was a you
know a supportive loving response yeah
there was still a prison that was
constructed around you that then you as
you described it in your video at a
certain point in your life you used took
over the can the construction of yeah
the prison the glass prison as you
called it exactly so I while my dad was
accepting of it that doesn't mean
everybody else in my immediate family
slash life was so it was difficult so
were they also ignorant of it they
didn't know about it or they just he
didn't tell him no my dad never said
anything to anybody your mom even I mean
I think yeah I mean I don't know for
sure but I I really don't think he said
anything to anybody because I don't
think he felt like it was his place hmm
and where was this where'd you grow up I
grew up in Southern California about 40
miles southeast of LA okay yeah and I
pretty much just stayed there my you
know my entire childhood we didn't move
around or anything so you kind of you
hinted at this in the video too and you
just said it some people were accepting
some people weren't
I mean Southern California is isn't it
didn't necessarily like hey I'm in South
Georgia and I'm coming out at 7 years
old or whatever but culturally like the
culture that you were involved in was a
conservative well it was very very very
conservative so it was just
no one really spoke of it and when it
people did speak about it
it was always in a negative way
so naturally I felt very uncomfortable
and isolated because I felt like
everyone else around me wasn't accepting
so I I think that's another reason why I
became so close with my dad because I
felt like he was my ally hmm I'd love to
continue to go back from the background
but I want to pick up with the New York
thing and then we'll go back more to the
background because I'm also interested
in you know just the YouTube story in
your whole career fascinating so in New
York having not come out to anyone
except for that 7 year old dream
confession to your dad yeah
in this meditative state that's when you
were starting to say okay I know what
the problem is and it's it's getting to
be too much to bear to not be myself
yeah was there was that the plane ride
back is that the plane ride where it was
like okay I'm gonna make the video or
was it what was it what decisions took
place in New York and what brought you
back it wasn't the I didn't decide to do
the video in New York that was much
closer to the actual video being posted
that was probably like a week out from
the video being posted I was on a plane
and I was like I'm gonna do this because
New York was you said basically a year
ago now yeah okay so and you're at the
time when you're in New York you're
still in a relationship with a man yes
that's correct
so what was your question again sorry
what decisions came from New York like
when you what brought you back and what
did you do at that point so in New York
I decided that this was something that I
couldn't stop that I was going to
eventually come out to people and
eventually the man that I was with I
didn't know the timing of it I didn't
know how it would happen and I was
terrified when I would think about it I
would just
I I would a lot of times tell myself no
you can just stay in this because you're
gonna hurt somebody that you care about
it you know it wouldn't really be that
hard to stay in this but I ultimately
made the decision that I need to strive
to be the most authentic version of
myself and I I think that I have an
obligation to myself to be me and to do
you know to give myself my best chance
that's my job that's my number one
obligation and number two my day job is
to be me so that was another factor not
only did I want to do this for myself
but it's like what I do I'm supposed to
be myself and so there was a lot of
guilt like layered into this in very
complex ways not only with the people
that I was hurting but feeling like I
wasn't being completely honest with my
viewers and it was it was really rough
so I just ultimately decided this is
going to happen I don't know when I
don't know how but I'm going to take
this step by step and now that I have
personally accepted that this is going
to happen we'll just take it in baby
steps and figure it out but one of the
things that made it so frightening was
the that relationship you were in which
how long had you guys been dating at
that point it was over a year and a half
so it was coming up on two years and
that so that was like the big thing
mm-hmm
yeah I was I was so terrified and also I
just felt so guilty because you know
just because I'm gay I'm a lesbian and I
have been in relationships with men and
you know this last relationship it
doesn't mean that I didn't care about
that person doesn't mean that I was just
like whatever happens happens I wish
concerned and worried and I wanted to be
as thoughtful as possible about it
because I realized this is another human
being this human being loves me cares
about me and you know I care about him
and I love him but not in that deep way
and what did he think you were in New
York doing like sort de sorting things
out personally and did he yeah just you
know because I tend to be a little bit
of a free spirit so he just thought oh
you know this is Ingrid going off being
like her creative self so I don't think
anybody really had any idea that all of
this was going on while I was there and
then when you came back how did you
start to roll this out um I well first I
lived in my head a lot I did a lot of
writing and I remember just kind of
feeling like I couldn't be the first
step was I couldn't be in this
relationship with somebody that I do
care about but it's not a full real
relationship I couldn't keep leading him
on essentially that's what I felt like I
felt like I was leading him on and so it
wasn't something that happened
immediately it took me time to you know
go from deciding okay this is what I'm
gonna do and then you know initiating a
breakup conversation which was really
difficult especially when you're out of
phase in a relationship where you're
considering moving in and you know
getting more serious I think that period
of time being with someone for about two
years you're starting to think about
those things and so it was really
difficult but I told myself you have to
do this because it's better to do it now
than to get into something deeper and
then drop this in it and at least from
your in the way you anticipate at that
point was kind of like you
blindsiding him yeah there was no
indication I don't even know what he
thought you can tell us but at this
point before like having that
conversation
the assumption is from you I'm about to
blindside him pretty much so you call it
you call a meeting huh I mean
logistically how do you go about this so
I'm gonna make you a private youtube
video cuz I'm good at those
just watch this did you think about
doing it that way well I mean there what
happened was the relationship ended so
we officially broke up and it wasn't
until it took me about a month after we
broke up to actually tell him I'm gay oh
so that's what happened and when we were
going through the process I remember him
saying something to me and I have to say
that this is the most kind and
supportive you know parting that I have
ever experienced I think we were both
really thoughtful and kind throughout
the entire thing and he still is very
supportive so I feel lucky for that and
I remember him saying you know I feel
like there's this unstoppable force
within you where you are beginning to
really step into the shoes that you are
meant to wear and you know he wasn't
specific about it it was kind of vague
like that but he said it you know
there's this unstoppable force I can't
stop it like I just I see it coming I
see it happening within you and I just
kind of have to accept that and step to
the side because this is something
that's really important and he didn't
know exactly what it was but it was said
that was the breakup yeah the cup was he
initiated it it was it kind of started
as a conversation that was I guess you
know it was almost initiated by both of
us because we could each tell you know
that something wasn't quite right and
and you knew a little more than he did
yes yes I know a little bit more that
wasn't the moment - okay well then yeah
it didn't it didn't start
office by the way yeah it didn't start
off as like I'm gonna go into this as a
breakup conversation
it started as you know I think a
conversation with the two of us
realizing that we needed to talk and
then he's probably expecting something
after you have this period of time in
New York like she's gonna come back with
some sort of I mean it was revelation
about something yet there were months in
between that okay got it we we still you
know there were things that were
happening in between that time and we
just had to talk about everything and so
you broke up and under vague for like he
had a vague premonition that he put in a
positive light like this is gonna be
good for you great things are ahead for
you we need to move on and so then later
you went back to him about a month later
about a month later you go back to him
you know I'm about to fill you in on
some of the of the details yeah I was
very direct with him and his reaction
was oh was it that it was like a lot
more makes sense now and I think he
handled it perfectly and I think it was
actually I guess I mean I can't imagine
any other way now since this is what
actually happened but I think it was
good because we had that period of time
it's a kind of mourn the relationship
and so by that point you know he wasn't
in the midst of it or anything he had
had some he was having an emotional
wreck had some separation and so when I
told him I'm sure that there was still a
lot to process but it was much different
than hey we're breaking up
also I'm gay so go deal with that you
know and he wasn't the first person that
you told no no the first person that I
told was my friend cat and that came
after driving 50 miles up the coast and
stopping at this random spot there were
just these rocks
and she happened to be there she
happened to be that she was waiting for
on the PCH yeah so I drove I had been
doing this Drive a lot for some reason
I've always found it really comforting
whenever I feel stressed or I'm anxious
or trying to process something I always
feel they need to get out whether it's
going on a walk just getting outside
going on a drive and driving aimlessly
that really helps me and for some reason
I kept gravitating towards this PCH
Drive it's pretty iconic yeah it is but
for some reason I just kept wanting to
drive near water so this was the longest
drive that I did I drove about 50 miles
up from where I live and I stopped at
these rocks I sat there for so long and
that's when I had you know I just had
this playing in my head over and over
again that you know well you know
everyone deserves their best chance I
think this is time that I give myself my
best chance and I said what chance at
life like a real full happy life and so
when that hit then I was like well now I
have this urge like I need to tell
somebody I feel ready to tell somebody
and it was just like I was about to
burst and the first person that came to
my mind immediately without any
hesitation was my friend cat and she's
just always been somebody that I've been
able to talk openly with we've had
really intimate conversations and she
was one of those people that was like
you know I always kind of had a feeling
but I just you know I don't want to say
anything but because we had had these
intimate conversations she it wasn't a
total shock for her and I've just always
felt comfortable talking to her about
anything I think she's one of the most
open-minded people that I know and she's
always working on herself she always
wants to improve herself and that's
something that I really admire about her
and
that's I think a big reason why I felt
so comfortable telling her I just I knew
Kat has to be the person this may sound
like stupid question it may be one I
have a knack for asking those sometimes
but so when you come out to your best
friend your best girlfriend is there a
moment where it's like did she I don't
I'm not crushing on you or were you or
are you or well I don't think she ever
had you know
maybe she did have that thought actually
I didn't ask her but she never expressed
it and I'm sure if she did have that
thought she would have told me because
she's just that kind of person but I
didn't ever feel like I had to tell her
well you know I've never had a crush on
you so don't start thinking that like
this isn't my love confession to you we
didn't talk about that at all and I
think if she had that question she would
have asked me because when I told her we
sat talking for about two-and-a-half
hours or so but I did have an experience
like that with my friend after I came
out to her we were in a situation where
we were gonna share a bed and you know
in the past it would just be something
where it's like we're just sharing it
back but I felt like I felt like I had
to preface it with but it's okay don't
worry like nothing's gonna happen and
she's like Ingrid calm down it's okay it
was you bringing that yeah she's like
eager and it's fine shut up stop it
okay so shortly after that I guess you
you you tell a few other people and how
quickly do you know or was it also when
you were on the rock that you knew I've
got to tell my fans as well that this is
part of this or was that sort of like a
secondary thing yeah that was kind of in
the back of my mind I knew that that
would be a thing eventually but my main
concern was telling the people around me
first and then once I got through that
phase then I would deal with the next
phase and something that I've always
known about myself and I think people
around me
now once I commit to something once I
have made a decision it's like I go full
speed ahead so once I just you know once
I told Kat I was basically plowing
through everybody on my list and coming
out because it felt amazing to tell Kat
and I couldn't stand being around these
people all the time or talking to them
and not having them know did some of
those moments not go well they all went
really well I mean I told a very small
group of people and everybody was really
supportive and it was interesting to see
everybody's you know initial facial
reactions because some people you know
immediately jumped up and smiled and
some people were very calm about it so
it was just really interesting to see
these sides of people that but no one
made that like face like something
stinks but you don't want to no no no
act like you submerge something
no no but these were also fun at lesbian
smell I don't I mean I did she's
checking their armpits right
I put deodorant on today I will say I
don't know if it works so well because I
had to reapply it twice yesterday so I
actually said before I change switch up
well I said before coming over here I
hope I don't stick because my deodorants
a little questionable so these were
mostly friends so you kind of
anticipated a positive reception from
them but did this also include coming
out to people back home family I came
out to one family member
everyone else I'm not as close with in
my family so I you know I kind of
narrowed down the list of people that I
was going to come out to two people that
were I guess immediately in my life and
important to me and so it was difficult
coming out to that one person but I
would say that I'm just not close with
the rest of my family at this point
so I that wasn't something that was a
part of the experience so before we get
into the the coming out video I just
think it's I would just like to hear how
you know when you talk about you what
does it really mean to not be your true
self as an experience I mean maybe just
within the microcosm of a relationship
with a guy when what what is that like
when you know that this is not who I
truly am and I love this guy but it's
not that kind of it's not a romantic
love and if that even work in is there
from his perspective is it like oh this
was never fully clicking now that I look
back on it or was it something that you
were just really good at suppressing I
think I was really good at suppressing
it but also sometimes also good at
suppressing it and I think that I was
good at suppressing it for a while and
then it got to a point where I became
frustrated with the situation that I had
built for myself and I became frustrated
with myself and it really was just like
going through the motions that I thought
I had to go through and I think I mean
like acting like you're attracted to
someone physically yeah when you're not
yeah it feels very mechanical that's
what it feels like it feels mechanical
and you in the midst of that you knew
this is it was it I know that I'm
basically acting to kind of play this
role or was it like I don't know maybe
someday this will take maybe maybe I can
be directed yeah I think you know
especially earlier on in a relationship
it's much easier to suppress and then
when you get deeper into it and you
actually start caring about somebody if
he comes much more difficult and I was
not a good actress once we started to
get deep into it
you know I I was running away from a lot
a lot a lot a lot and I think it it was
just some
that I I couldn't continue to keep doing
and in my mind I would think you know
maybe if I keep doing this it will just
become what I I'm telling myself what I
want to want because this is the easier
path and that was a big difference you
know wanting to want something and what
I actually want did you believe that it
was wrong or what was your motivation to
to put yourself through this and other
people I guess I guess because it had
started so early on in my life and it
you know I explained it as it's not
something that I started for myself it
was you know my surroundings and I being
young wanted love and acceptance so I
would start doing these things that I
didn't want to do I would be a person
that I didn't want to be and then
eventually you kind of just get in the
groove of that and it really sucks it's
like you get used to being someone
that's not fully you and it really
really sucks and then it's almost like
you're a robot in a way and you just get
used to it
you adapt and you just tell yourself
over and over well you know so many
other people have it way worse why are
you complaining like just keep going so
was it you were doing this because you
wanted to like fit somebody's
expectations that's exam was entirely
that this is wrong and I got to suppress
this was it was a world thing from your
background or was you know partially
while having you know my dad be
supportive everything else around was
pretty negative and so how did that
impact your particular perspective on it
it made me feel like it was something
that I had to hide that it was bad that
you know I'm not gonna be loved for this
people are going to treat me you know
horribly and I just want to
to be loved and accepted by people
around me and now I realize you know I
was seeking love and acceptance from
people that I don't want love and
acceptance from if they're they're gonna
have that kind of mindset and I think
this you can kind of transition back
into the video that you make to tell
everybody about this was there also you
know given which we haven't really got
into talking specifically because this
is just a big thing in your life right
now but specifically about what it is
you do on YouTube and what your the
brand is and what the angle is how much
did that factor into think okay I am
missglamorazzi it's about beauty and
makeup and how you know stereotypically
people might describe as girly things
this girl doesn't seem like a lesbian so
how much did that factor into the
decision and did you worry that coming
out was going to impact a brand in a
negative way honestly I was so in my
head that I I wasn't thinking about
anything business-related at all
I was like how am I gonna survive this
personally how am I gonna do this in a
thoughtful way with the people around me
and how am I gonna do this in a
thoughtful way to my viewers and in that
sense I don't see that as like a
business thought so it wasn't until
after I posted the video and I was
reading comments that all of that
started to click in and I was just me oh
my god these are things that I never
thought about I was reading posts on
tumblr that girls had written that I
would just read and cry because I had no
idea that people were going through
these things and that my video relating
to your story yeah and I I think what
was interesting in the comments was to
see because there's this there's this
big this is a difference between you
know the public reaction to me coming
out and people in my personal life that
reaction I would say for the most part
people in my personal life were like you
know we kind of knew but on the flip
side
public reaction everybody's like whoa oh
my gosh and the number one thing was oh
my gosh
I'm so shocked you don't look like a
lesbian right and and that's when I
realized oh my gosh like this this has
nothing to do with how I look this has
nothing to do with my superficial
interest my aesthetic taste what I what
music I listen to it has nothing to do
with that at all but you know I because
of this experience I've realized more so
now than ever that these stereotypes are
perpetuated especially in the lesbian
community and I think it's because you
know there isn't a lack of lesbians that
are feminine it's a lack of
representation in traditional media and
you didn't and it sounds like you didn't
expect to be you're representing kind of
tearing down a wall in people's
perspectives and I did not think about
that at all I it set in when I read the
first post by a girl on tumblr I was
just going through these Tumblr posts
and I I wish I could remember the name
and she I remember her saying that my
video meant so much to her because she
went down a similar path and she's never
been able to see herself reflected in
the community with like a more public
figure and I was just crying reading
that post and that's when I realized oh
my god this is a real this is a real
thing because it wasn't something that I
thought about before cuz I was so in
here like how am I gonna do this in a
thoughtful way and then I realized oh my
god there are all of these stereotypes
that exist and it has nothing to do with
how people look at all at all and so
that's kind of like my personal mission
now is to just hopefully break that down
and to show people that you know it's
about who I love fully and deeply it's
not about all that
this external yeah how do you in
interpret the the fact that this is now
your most viewed video well what does
that say back what does that say about
the audience I and then just how do you
feel about it I I mean it's still very
overwhelming to think about but it makes
me feel good because I think overall you
know the comments that I've seen the the
tweets that I've read from people the
posts that I've read people have been
very very supportive and you know I've
read posts where it seems to be helping
people and that's just one of my main
things in life like when I'm an old
woman on my deathbed and you know if I'm
thinking about this wonderful life that
I've lived one of the things that you
know contributed to that wonderful life
is helping people and to see that this
is helping people it just it makes me
very emotional and I have two hectares
because I'm very proud to crying
especially with this but it is
overwhelming to know that that many
people have seen the video because I
wasn't expecting it it was like I'm
doing this for me and I'm doing this for
my viewers because I feel like I have
this personal connection with them and
they have been with me for all of these
years and this is something that I want
them to know I wasn't expecting it to be
a thing that got shared with people
outside of you know my little community
right and I think that that's an
interesting dynamic because your video
is kind of you know there have been a
number of other coming out videos for
people that it may have been really
unexpected some people may have
anticipated or unexpected
there's something about a coming out
video that it usually is the most
popular video on a person's Channel
and you know you know it's an
interesting dynamic right I mean what do
you think that says about this the
current climate on YouTube that that's
the kind of thing that ends up popping
bigger than maybe anything else anybody
does I think you know one of the big
reasons why that's you know people are
gravitating towards these coming out
videos is the level of vulnerability
you're in them and I think that
vulnerability just in general you know
in your real life opens up so many doors
because it allows you to be your truest
self you're putting yourself out there
and I think people can see that in these
videos and you know how much more
intimate can you really get you know I
think that this is something that's so
personal and so much a part of people
where it's not all of a person but it's
a very intimate part of them and in
these coming out videos I think you see
that vulnerability and people and I
think people recognize that they can see
it and they appreciate it yeah because
there's something about peeling back
layers of personality that you know
there's that tension with where the with
somebody who shares their life it's like
the further I pull this back the more
intimate of a connection I have with
with my viewers and then you pull
something like that back and it's like
well this has been true all along and
now we know about it we got to talk
about it we got to share it we got a
comment on it yeah it's just that's the
that's how and of course this in the
issue of sexuality is such a hot issue
it always has been but especially right
now with the debate about gay marriage
in our country and so this is just
something that is sort of just beneath
the surface and with everybody and
everybody wants to yeah I think
everyone's curious people are curious
too and I think that you know people who
aren't struggling with their sexuality
still connect with these videos because
of that level of vulnerability you know
think it's about accepting yourself not
just your sexuality when part of that
part of the fascination and part of the
the buzz around the video like this it
does you know it isn't just the fact
that oh isn't this kind of ironic she's
the lesbian makeup girl or however
people wanted to say it but how does it
make you feel about your brand and he's
moving forward potentially being branded
in that way if that's how people would
refer to you it's because you have your
initial fan base you know millions of
people watch your videos this isn't a
part of your brain but tens of millions
of people watch this video and that
might be what people know of you yeah I
mean well if it's what they know of me
it's what they know of me but it's not
how I define myself I am a woman and
being a lesbian is part of being a woman
for me and it's as simple as that my
brand is about being a woman and this is
just part of that I do have specific
have you thought now that this is kind
of rolled out and you've got this
reaction have you thought about how to
manage that moving forward it's been
like okay well I don't want you know I
know how people are and people like to
put people in a box and people like to
put descriptors on people especially
with sexuality especially if there's
something that seems juicy or ironic has
that impacted you know videos and your
brand moving forward you know I think
I've been in this kind of evolutionary
process just in general I'm like in this
transitional phase in my life very
transitional and I think that's been
reflected in my content for a while and
I I don't really feel the need to you
know explain myself or do things
differently because of this I'm gonna
keep doing and creating what feels
natural to me and exploring different
things than just following that natural
evolution and because I have opened up
like this this just makes me feel more
liberated to create the things that I
really want to create mmm and the things
that are meaningful to me I'm interested
in your
start on YouTube and how having such an
important section of who you are as a
person being so secret and having that
struggle and in parallel you're putting
yourself out there on the internet and I
mean what the first video that I don't
know if it was the first one you made
but its first one is still public with
the red lipstick yeah yeah you know what
what what you know what went into that
video did you have any inkling that you
would become the missglamorazzi though
that everyone now knows especially now
now knows you know absolutely not
that wasn't the first video that ever
went live on my channel the first one
you can barely see me because it's like
so dark and I don't think I really said
that much because I had no idea what to
say it was a hair curling tutorial but I
had no idea absolutely no idea when I
started this was how old were you I was
20 okay so it wasn't something that I
was thinking you know later down the
line this is gonna be your job no not at
all
it wasn't I want to make this a career
it was this will be fun it was something
that I did because I was trying to
overcome a fear I had made a goal for
myself I remember it was in high school
you know when they give you like the
little planners for did you guys get
planners in school no like a trapper
keeper like a like a daily planner okay
so they would hand out a daily planner
every year and one year in high school
it was in my high school well we didn't
plan anything we I think it was
something that happened you know when I
was later in high school so I didn't
know how about starting off but I
remember in this planner there were
quotes every single day and one of them
encouraged people you know it's
basically said the best way to gain
confidence is to do the things that
you're afraid of doing and so when I
read that that's stuck with me
and I decided I'm gonna make this a goal
for myself to do things that I'm afraid
of and I was so shy so so so so shy but
I always had all of these thoughts and
ideas and I wanted to be able to share
them with people and I had discovered
out of boredom one summer people making
videos on YouTube and I was a tomboy for
most of my life and I just started
getting into makeup around like 1920
more so 20 and I didn't really have
anyone around me in my life that I could
talk to it up you know talk about makeup
with and so I found these girls you know
doing holes talking about makeup and I
was like oh my god I'm learning so much
and I decided maybe I should combine
something that I'm really afraid of
talking to people that I don't know and
something that I find really interesting
right now that I am currently learning a
lot about put those two things together
and like just put myself out there and
make myself vulnerable and do something
that I'm really afraid of and it was
something that I did for myself so when
I posted that video it felt really great
and no one watched it for a while and I
felt really good I was like oh my god I
just did something that I was terrified
of and then I realized after a couple
weeks people started watching the video
and that's what I freaked out a little
bit cuz I was like oh my god these are
real people like leaving comments on
this video watching it responding to it
oh my gosh so that was something else
that I had to process but ultimately
people encouraged me to keep posting
videos and I decided well you know it
still really freaks me out but I feel a
little bit better so I'm gonna keep
doing it and eventually I just started
to grow into myself more more and more
and more and I I really just grew to
love it so much I loved it from the
beginning and I just grew to love it
even more I think yeah I find it
interesting I think and I don't know if
you
all your fans already knew this that the
makeup thing was kind of a late
development and you were almost kind of
like learning at the same time that you
were teaching yeah how can i phrase this
is there a was there anything going on
in your life at that time nineteen
twenty where you were kind of dealing
with the with thoughts about your
sexuality and you thought well maybe
I'll do some of this this stuff that's
more traditionally considered girly as a
as a way to combat what's going on with
me inside
well I'm anchoring one fear of putting
yourself out there but also insulating
yourself more by meeting expectations of
like a stereotypical non lesbian no I I
don't think it had anything to do with
that I think I just genuinely had an
interest for makeup and fashion and it
wasn't something that I really explored
in the past and I was like this is now
interesting to me and it had nothing to
do with you know my sexuality which at
that point was very suppressed
especially you know when you're at that
age and people are hooking up with each
other and I'm just like oh my god oh my
god oh my god my body wants to do all
these things and oh my god so you stay
so the channels started to take off like
really ramped up were you doing a lot of
videos like every week I mean uh it grew
it actually grew pretty steadily and
slowly it wasn't like an overnight
success or anything which I really loved
because I was able to form like an
intimate relationship with the people
that were watching my videos and also
with other creators that were doing
similar things and it just kind of
slowly grew from there sorry what was
the question yeah just how how often you
were posting how quickly through um I
didn't really have a schedule at that
point it's just whenever I had free time
to film some videos I would but was it
always a slow growth or did something
really pop like OH
lipstick is really rare really pop this
is the reddest of all the breads
I think it's always been just very
steady gradual growth I mean it's been
you know more and more but I don't think
there was ever a time where it was like
this is the big pink moment or anything
like that it's always just been like did
you just steadily going and I think
that's you know that's that's actually
what I prefer because I think if it had
been this really quick success I would
have probably backed out from it because
I would have felt overwhelmed but
because I started off with like this
small group of people that I you know
would I would answer all of their
comments
I was forming intimate relationships
with other Creators and developing real
friendships that I still have to this
day it was something really special and
I wouldn't want to change that I
wouldn't want to go back and you know be
an overnight success I really loved that
period of time where I had that slow
gradual growth okay so let's come up to
the present you know you're you're
you're living in the in the post coming
out mega video and so now what and I I
guess specifically okay let's talk about
the Hagrid thing oh my god okay here's
it like from Harry Potter right yes the
character so the next video you release
two videos later it's a video with
Hannah Hart and it's the first in your
series of sense of self which is really
cool first of all tell us about that
series so I never want to know about
that um sense of self is a series that I
just started on my channel where it
basically stems from my personal
noisiness
I love looking into people's homes and
when I was in New York at this Airbnb I
walked down the street and I would
actually go up people's Stoops and like
look in their windows you would you
would peek in yeah I mean nobody's a
video camera and
made a series oh yeah pretty much that's
exactly what it is it's cribs meets
Ingrid yeah so I want youtubers exactly
like I wanted to go into youtubers
spaces and show people things that they
may not know about especially because
you know a lot of people shoot within
their personal space or they have a
studio and there are these things that
people may see around but they don't
know the story behind them and I find
the people in my life
fascinating I think youtubers are
fascinating so I want a cool idea I
wanted people to learn more about some
of their favorite people but the first
person you choose is Hannah Hart and so
the comments explode because I mean this
is basically within a week or two of of
your coming-out video and they're just
talking about how okay I ship them I
ship them so hard you know putting you
guys in this relationship together and
so now you know we're just we're gonna
play right into that now that but there
was at least one comment I'm sure there
were many of these too
don't ship to them just because they're
good I was just gonna say there were
people who you know people who would say
you know don't ship them they're real
people and just because they're lesbians
does it mean they have to date you know
so there were those comments but you did
describe Hannah as a wonderful dinner
that lingers late into the evening that
you want to keep going oh my god how red
is my face it's dimly lit in here I
gotta go okay great and then you were on
the my drunk kitchen it was kind of like
you guys ik exchanged she was on your
show you were on her show yeah I mean
Hannah and I have always gotten along
really well and I think that we've
always just had a really great
connection and I I've always found her
to be one of the most interesting people
in my life I think she has an incredible
story and I think she's a wonderful
person so I thought she was you know the
perfect person to start that series oh
well if the internet you know the
internet is shipping you guys are you
shipping you guys
all right I'm just gonna say yes I ship
it but I will let you guys know that the
official name voted by people on tumblr
is hand grid and not Hagrid okay yes
okay that apparently there was an
official vote I didn't know that people
so there was a Hagrid but that sounds it
was there was a hat this is is it bad
that I know this match but people
it was either people really loved Hagrid
because you know Harry Potter or they
really didn't like Hagrid because of
Harry Potter because it was too hard to
search because all of the Harry Potter
stuff that would be up or vice versa
maybe Harry Potter people were just like
what is this who are these people that
are just showing up so I guess there was
an official vote that happened some time
but I just saw this on tumblr and it was
reposted a bunch and people voted so to
clarify based on that official vote you
are now officially dating that official
vote oh my god okay so your vlog and you
said I'm so excited
just in moving on with your life I mean
I would just I just wanted to kind of
unpack that a little bit just that was
how you ended this fog for 19 minutes
you talk about guys this is what I've
been through this has been my life and I
found it extremely inspiring that that
you were able to say that at the end and
it I felt great for you so don't unpack
that a little bit the I'm so excited I
you know I didn't know exactly what was
to come
I don't know what's gonna happen in the
future but I just felt so optimistic
because I I was essentially giving
myself permission to live a full happy
life and I think that a lot of people
who find themselves unhappy realize that
a big barrier in the road
happiness is themselves and it just it
feels so wonderful to be on the other
side and just exploring this open life I
think one of the the biggest things for
me is the relationships that I have
around me I feel like are more honest
and they're more true and they're deeper
because I've shattered that glass wall
and I'm giving myself to people and in
turn they're giving pieces of themselves
that I've never seen to me and that's
something that's so special to me my
relationships are really really
important to me and it's just been
amazing to see sides of people in my
life that I've never seen before and to
feel like wow we have a real
relationship now this is incredible and
I feel the same way with my online
community too I feel like we just we had
a moment where we just really connected
and now you know everybody's just kind
of moving forward which feels great and
they're gonna be bumps in the road but
it just it feels good to be me it really
does
well that vulnerability resonates
through the internet and through real
life and we appreciate you coming on
here and being vulnerable with us and
thank you now it's time to sign the
table oh my god I'm so excited
thanks for coming in thank you for
having me
[Music]
and there you have it our conversation
with Ingrid really appreciated being a
part of that conversation and hey let
her know what you think of her story and
our talk here
tweet at her that's Ingrid Nilsen in il
se en use hashtag ear biscuits I'm sure
she would appreciate hearing from you
guys right cuz it's obviously it's not
easy to make the video that she made
mm-hmm but it's also not easy to come on
here and talk to us asking her a bunch
of question be grilled about it you know
and so yes so just let her know that you
appreciate that I know I know we did I
think that's one of the great things
about what having a longer conversation
with somebody is you're actually able to
get context you know that you don't
always get when you're just hearing from
one person in a vlog so thanks to Ingrid
and you know you can count on us to
contextualize more conversations we're
going to do that next week so you can
count on us to bring another one into
your ear and in the meantime you can
support internat Ament by getting some
merch at rhettandlink.com/store
we got bobble heads we got hoodies
posters wristbands shirts coffee mugs
hoverboards and Foley catheter Oh check
that out rhettandlink.com/store thanks
for your support guys and for your ears
for giving us your ear just one hour a
week that's all we need like don't mail
us your ears don't even put that thought
into people's heads erase that thought
from it like a van Gogh don't do that
please don't do that we will not open it
not open well we'll open it and then
we'll see that it's an American smell in
here we'll close it back smell in here
return to sender
[Music]
[Music]